I am currently a test engineering
manager and I support the material
mechanical testing in my role I manage
multiple projects the course in project
management through UMass has really
helped me enhance my overall performance
at work hi I'm Lisa Luc Casey my
expertise lies in developing fast
effective and relevant strategies I was
in the medical device industry for 15
years one of the projects that I'm very
proud of is the development of wound
dressings for severely bleeding injuries
for the military we will were able to
get the second fastest FDA approval and
awarded the 2004 top 10 greatest army
inventions career growth is not an
option without great teams taking this
project management course was an
opportunity for me to develop those
skills the program consisted of five
parts upon completion of this course I
was able to pass my PMP through the
project management Institute and my
agile scrum Master certifications upon
the first attempt my favorite part was
the Capstone project at the end this
gave me the opportunity to apply my
learnings practically and this is very
useful for my current
role I've struggled with mental health
challenges throughout my life and sports
have been a way for me to work through
those
challenges as an adult I started taking
Cor body with my daughter and earned my
black belt when I was 40 and my second
deegree black belt when I was
45 I have co-authored two books focusing
on the mindset of athletes the first one
is maximum
composure and the second one is Lucidity
in sports and this year we have a new
book coming out when I am encouraged and
supported to embrace my diverse skills
and experiences I'm able to tap into my
superpowers as a fast learner adaptable
team
leader as a mother of two my greatest
dream is for my children to find their
superpowers and to create a Wonderful
Life and a better world for everyone
around them like me they are excited for
what their future
holds